It is time for "Tonight Show
Hashtags." Here we go!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week where I send out
a hashtag and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So, this week I sent out
#3WordResolution.
And I asked you to tweet out
your new year's resolution
in just three words.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We do it every week.
Thank you, thank you.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
3WordResolution tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one is @2much2do56.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @vidman.
He says...
Well, that sounds good.
[ Applause ]
This one's from
@RyanBartholomee. He says...
There you go.
This one's from @lb64.
She says...
Ah. Respect. Respect.
This one's from
@DunderMifflin84. They say...
Hey, not bad.
I like that idea.
Tonight Dough.
This one's from @CallieGrayActs.
She says...
Ah, yeah. "Lost."
-"I don't know
where it went to."
-This one's from
@Juliacollinsart. She says...
-"Thy"?
Why the "thy"?
-What?
-Why "thy"?
-What are you talking about?
-"Floss thy teeth"?
What is that? Forsooth!
-"Floss thy teeth."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from
@TheRealOlMusky. He says...
[ Laughter ]
It's a thing. It's a thing.
-They know each other.
-This one's from @Isleeya.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh. Get it?
-This one's from @ItsLoRadio.
She says...
That's pretty good.
This last one's from
@Shannonmccready. She says...
Hey!
-Yeah!
-Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.